euh nous sommes arrivés hier nous trouvons
des prix violets avec les États-Unis
donc c'est très abordable
cela a été glorieux car c'est
notre quatrième ou cinquième voyage en Europe et
les taux de change ont toujours été euh
comme 1,35
1,4 dollar pour l'euro maintenant avec eux un
à  un euh, il semble que visiter un
lieu de vacances local aux États-Unis
[Musique] les
choses étrangères sont un peu plus abordables
pour nous
afin que nous puissions faire des choses que nous n'aurions peut-
être pas faites autrement, donc le coût du
voyage était moins cher qu'un hôtel était  un
peu moins cher la nourriture est un peu
moins chère et on peut faire des choses
qui sont des luxes que l'on apprécie à
l'étranger